do you ever wish you were in america so
you could be a marvel superhero
i would say
the thing is see
i love my gym that's the thing i just
love where i'm at there's no way i'll
ever ever if i didn't have my gym i'd
definitely be in the states somewhere
but my gym is what keeps me you know
grounded in new zealand and yeah covet
kind of like slowed things down
it didn't stop my my stock but slowed
things down yeah you know what i mean
but i would say i wish i was in america
i just wish we could travel like we used
to and i kind of am now because we're
we're stuck out of our country till what
is it mid-march so i'm like fire yeah so
i'm gonna be out here then i'm gonna go
to the uk and do some work over there
then i'm gonna come back this way and do
some stuff and
yeah we'll see what happens you're just
in an interesting place because
you know that if you lived in los
angeles or vegas that every action movie
would ask you to be in it yeah i've
already got a few offers already but we
didn't have a an 0-1 visa this is last
year this is a major marvel movie
go offer to to jump in at speaking royal
fighting role really yeah but then i
wouldn't have a 0-1 visa and i think to
get it was uh it was delayed a little
bit and for marvel to delay the shooting
by even the days like 160k so
yeah yeah so i'm just like fair enough
but now we've got one just so we stay
ready yeah yeah yeah i'm not gonna get
crazy where's tim tim's fault he's
already it's done tim's fired
gash on yeah no that's just one of those
things where like and i think you're
making the right decision because you're
you're leaning into the bread and butter
and you're leaning into what you do
great and yeah and the gym is what helps
you do that and there's responsibility
you have for other fighters too exactly
my man that's an important thing so for
me it's not just about me like they
helped me so when i go back i have to
help them and i see them on your cards
yeah like that's not coincidence no we
make that happen exactly i mean rising
tides lifts all the ships yeah 100 i
agree but there is a part of you and and
i've gone through this even in comedy
it's like there's a party who goes oh
the grass is greener over there and you
have to check that [ __ ] yeah because it
might be more miserable over there yeah
you might not get the training you need
you might be training with these hating
[ __ ] they're actually
videotaping you sending that [ __ ] around
a lot of snitches a lot of uh moles
sometimes and i've heard these stories
as well like moles in certain gyms and
you have too many big names in the gym
sometimes
egos get involved chelsea was giving it
up to you i think he was like
that even earlier in your career you
said that you couldn't come
help out uh training or maybe dc was
giving up yeah and it was like earlier
in your career you couldn't come uh
train with him because you because luke
rockhold worked out there and you knew
that you were gonna fight him eventually
and he was like this is before people
knew before i was living in the ufc no
yeah before i was in the ufc this was in
2015 the ufc domination 2015. even funny
thing is like there's a picture i posted
um from the weigh-ins when um there was
ufc 192 dc fought gus uh
gustafson
and i was there i was at the weigh-ins
because dan was fighting and after
everyone cleared out i like looked
around people and i just went on the
stage and i was just like on the scale
just like and i just pictured that
moment in the same
toyota center yeah and then the security
was like wait get the [ __ ] off the stage
right about a rod i jumped off the stage
but then when i made that actual step in
the same arena yeah it felt like yeah
just the way i saw it every time i'm at
a knicks game yeah i
i i take a moment where i don't look at
the
floor yeah i turn around and i look at
the people oh wow yeah
yeah okay this is what it will be just
in case you get in the mba yeah exactly
yeah
yeah this is uh yeah your ability to
kind of plan these things and execute
them it's manifestation man i feel like
it's a superpower and this is one thing
i say about work yeah right of course
you can't just
you can't was a bisping said that line
to rocco lewis dream it believe it
achieve it yeah it doesn't work without
the work you need to work you need to
actually there's one thing even if you
work without all that you can still get
some places but then when you have that
working as well it's honestly magic and
i've done it so in so many levels of my
life that it's like it gets scary it
gets scary that i'm just like yeah how
did i make this happen
do you get do you ever get emotional
when it comes to fruition yeah isn't
that kind of crazy like it does like i
mean there was even a moment on my um
youtube channel freestyle man to check
it out yes um at the weigh-in where my
my teammate blood diamond stepped on the
scale and i didn't realize
that um jeff was filming he was over on
this side
and i remember because it was i was
sitting down right and we're backstage
and there's a screen it's just big and
he just stepped up there and and i just
like it just felt like it just
and i just oh man because we've just
been through so much together and he's
been through so much yeah and he didn't
have the best result this weekend but
for me sam carlos didn't have the best
result in his ufc debut but look at him
this weekend you know i mean so i know
what we're capable of i know as a team
yeah so when i saw that moment i just it
just i just got welled up and i was just
like
oh just so much love for my team man
honestly yeah you have the right
perspective on it and it's very easy to
get caught up in like selfish endeavors
yeah you know i mean because you're
going to get thrown so many things this
happens with bands all the time yeah and
it's like they split the [ __ ] up and
then they realize like oh [ __ ]
these components make me special these
components make wasn't just me it get a
lot of people get like it's eager for
people
you gotta understand it's ego like
people think like you know
i've seen it and so even in this game in
my in my own personal way sometimes you
get people who kind of like
what's that meek mill line never watch
your your homies pockets and think you
deserve it you know they think like oh
you know
i you know it should be me it should be
me and it's like that that would eat you
alive because i've had that when i was
younger i had that when i was younger um
one of my boys was working in the mines
and
long story short i pretty much just kind
of like started to feel a little weight
because he was making like 2 500 a week
yeah i started feeling a little weight
and i was like what is that doing for me
like why am i feeling jealous about
what he's doing with his life it has
nothing to do with me so
i had to look within myself and identify
that monster and when i did yep i killed
it yeah yeah yeah it's just tricky
especially when it comes to
to what you do specifically because you
can only be in the cage
by yourself yeah right they can't be in
there with you that being said all those
things that they do to help you that
culmination of all that but it's so easy
to get caught up in your own ego
especially if you're insecure you want
to believe what everybody tells you yeah
and you get all these deals and all
these things that's why i just i really
admire you not leaving i appreciate like
likewise like rocking with when tim told
me you're rolling with 12 people i'm
like i got like i had a little smile to
my face like i didn't get emotional but
i was like
i rolled deep or for real i rolled well
i saw you on the tour man you were like
one thing i liked was the promo the way
you you came through like a like a rock
star and i was like yeah that's how you
do it even this this this fight uh fight
week i kind of thought you know similar
vibes i was like man i need to flex on
these [ __ ] a little bit let
them know let them know like because i
got it like that yes
i saw the bus down ap i'm hanging out
today
i might get another one after this
flight okay let me just for fun just for
fun
you know come on of course this is light
easy easy oh yeah but no i just think
it's beautiful you gotta take your
people and a lot of people don't realize
that it's very easy to get caught up in
that feeling where where you go well i'm
the only one doing that like i'm the
only person on stage i'm like no it's
[ __ ] that make this happen
so i mean i remember when i pulled up to
rogue and i pulled up a rogue with like
eight people and he's like dude it's
covet bro like yeah
and then the guys had to go shooting and
[ __ ] like that but still it's like i
don't go do rogan by myself of course
you
bring the boys the boys yeah right so
everybody gotta i [ __ ] love it
everyone hasn't has a role and everyone
on the team knows their
the importance of their role if you will
yeah yeah yeah and that's what that
what's like a long sustained career i
think ends up being is when you have
those parts you look at the rolling
stones yeah and these [ __ ] have
all done interesting things in their
lives individually but they still stay
together and they rock that out